the new pixel8 Pro looks very impressive
but can't it compete with the iPhone 15
Pro Max well today we're going to
compare everything that's not on the
spec sheet like the quality of the
displays speakers overheating
performance memory speed real world
cameras and more now I've been a fan of
the pixel lineup for a long time I
actually owned the first pixel phone
which wasn't even called a pixel way
back in the day but they've always had a
lot of tradeoffs this year Google seems
to have really stepped it up now you
guys see we have the obsidian black
color and it definitely looks nice and
that camera bump is the same size as
before but we now have this unibrow that
is huge and viim do you see the lens in
that thing dude it's massive that thing
is massive the camera upgrades are huge
on this thing let's look at both side by
side I mean the iPhone has a huge camera
bump but this pixel makes the Iphone
look small now holding it in the hand it
does feel very comfortable and what's
interesting is that the pixel8 pro
actually weighs less than the 15 Pro Max
even though the iPhone's made out of
titanium but when I'm holding him in the
hand because of the topheavy pixel
design it actually feels heavier the
width is about the same but the pixel is
taller overall even though they both
have 6.7 in displays and this year the
iPhone also has a USB type C port and
both of them have the same speeds and as
far as charging they're also very
similar but the pixel has a larger
battery so charging times will be
roughly the same and as far as battery
life we know that with iOS the iPhones
are so well optimized that it will do
better in the real world and now I have
both these set up and you guys can see
that the bezels are thinner on the
iPhone helping to make it smaller but
I'm glad that the pixel has uniform
bezels all around now the lock screen
look really nice on both but when you
turn off the displays the always on
display on the pixel is similar to most
Androids where you just have some text
compared to full color and wallpaper on
the iPhone now our iPhone has that
Dynamic Island where we have face ID for
very secure Face Unlock and this year
Google said that their face unlock is
secure so if I go ahead and um to tap
the screen there you guys see that we
got a little circle around the camera
and setting it up they wanted a bunch of
angles on my face but it's still a
single photo now of course we have the
fingerprint unlock that works nice and
quickly so you have both options but of
course face ID is very convenient while
being very secure now what is crazy is
that the pixel goes up to 2400 nits on
its display but we're going to test it
out in the real world but before that
I've got to show you guys the coolest
power bank I have ever seen the Shar
geek 170 from our sponsor charge with an
iconic transparent prism silhouette
design and a huge 24,000 milliamp of
battery power which is just below the
limit to be Airline safe it puts out an
insane 170 watts of power which is
enough to fast charge three devices at
once with its three ports or you can go
all out and fast charge your iPhone 15
Pro while also fast charging your 16-in
MacBook Pro at 140 WS but my favorite
part is that it's ip4 water resistant
and it comes with a smart display which
shows you the wattage info and the
remaining battery life while also
accepting 140 WS input power for
recharging and you can order one today
using the link down in the description
below getting back to the displays one
of the things that sucked about pixels
that the screens were not as bright as
iPhones or Samsung so right here I'm
going to max out my brightness on both
of them and then looking at this mostly
white page to me they look fairly
similar now that is not a bad thing but
then we went outside and saw that the
iPhone was still brighter now when you
switch to dark theme with a mostly black
display it gets closer but the
highlights on the iPhone are still
brighter and even in our studio lighting
right next to the bright light the
iPhone is still brighter so I'm really
not sure what to say about that 2400
nits compared to 2000 maybe only under
the most extreme bright sunlight will it
get up there if there's not much white
on your screen now looking at HDR video
the iPhone still seems to be brighter
especially if there's a lot of bright
areas and if you're watching a scene
that has a lot of Darkness that's when a
pixel gets close but still slightly
dimmer than the iPhone and I think it
might just be tuning in terms of saving
battery life or things like that whereas
iPhone gives you just a little bit more
now with that said this is still the
closest the pixel has ever gotten by far
so it displays a nice upgrade for Pixel
owners now apart from that displays are
similar you have slightly more pixels on
the pixel but you can't really tell just
looking at it and both of them have up
to 120 HZ going all the way down to 1 HZ
now another area where the pixel has
been behind for years is the speakers
and the iPhone got an amazing update
this year so let's go ahead and see if
the pixel can keep
[Music]
up
you guys let me know your thoughts in
the comment section now in my opinion
one thing that might not come through uh
through YouTube is the pixel sounds kind
of unbalanced I'm getting a lot more
sound from the bottom speaker than the
earpiece even though the slot on the
earpiece is much larger than the one on
the iPhone the iPhone is louder it's
more balanced in has a bit more base so
while this is a good upgrade compared to
last year it still doesn't compete and
now I want to just take a second and
talk about pricing because we have a
difference Google did make the pixel 8
Pro $100 more than the pixel 7 Pro so
it's 1,000 bucks now but Apple did the
same we have $11,200 so we have a $200
difference now as far as storage and
we'll test out the speeds we do have a
difference 128 gig at the base compared
to 256 but the nice thing is for only 59
bucks you can jump up to 256 and then
both can hit a terabyte and you'll save
another 200 bucks on the pixel so it is
a better value and now let's get into
performance and we are going to start
out with storage speed I'm going to run
both of these and I do want to mention
that this is the 128 gig base version of
the pixel so if we take a look at the
speeds the iPhone does win out the read
speed is nice and fast on the pixel but
the right is fairly slow now if you do
spend $59 extra to get 256 the right
speed will come up but typically the
read speed won't so it still won't be as
fast but I think that is a great use of
money now the pixel does come with 12
gigs of RAM compared to 8 but
unfortunately geekbench 6 is not running
on this new pixel with the tensor G3 the
same thing with 3D Mark wildlife and 2u
and a bunch of performance apps now
thankfully I did find some benchmarks
that will work so we're running pass
Mark right now here are the full results
and as far as single thread we have
3,642 compared to
4565 that is a difference of 50% and as
far as floating Point math we have have
18,000 compared to
29,000 a difference of 60% and then
overall here we have a difference of
about 30% and then looking at the memory
speed the iPhone crushes the pixel as
well being 2 and half times faster at
that now of course this is not an app we
typically use but we needed to find
something to show you guys and we know
that the new A7 Pro with 3 nmet is a lot
more powerful than Google's tensor G3
and now let's run the speedometer 2.0
web browsing test which does a bunch of
different tests to see just how fluid
and fast your experiences this also
applies to web-based Applications you
guys see we have 465 on the iPhone it
did the test more than twice as fast and
we have a score of 132 on the pixel
using optimized Google Chrome that is
over three times faster and it just
shows that the A7 is a crazy chip and
even though the tensor G3 is an
improvement it's not huge and now let's
go ahead and take a look at graphics
performance this is the basem mark GPU
test offscreen now I ended up having to
do a custom test just to make sure the
settings align and if we look at the
overall score we have a difference of
40% but one thing that came up is that
the iPhone's actually limited the
maximum FPS because of the 120 HZ screen
so if we look at the minimum FPS here
that is a difference of 60% now I really
wish we can run 3D Marks Wildlife
extreme but overall we know that if
you're buying a pixel you're not buying
it for maximum performance there's a lot
of Android phones out there that are a
lot more powerful and I'm running this
test back to back um the iPhone's
already done it once before you guys
could see just how quickly it moves I'm
going to run this for about 5 minutes
which is enough to get the iPhone to
really throttle down and we'll see what
we get as far as thermals all right so
it's been over 5 minutes and looking at
the backs of the phone you guys could
see that the iPhone has a ton of heat on
one section right there 37° C the pixel
36 at the peak so not far off but the
heat is spreading out much more evenly
on the pixel compared to the iPhone
where it's right there next to the chip
which of course isn't great for
performance even though it performs a
lot better it will throttle more now you
can help that with one of these coolers
this one is the razor one and it is
magnetic with mag safe so that is really
nice and we actually did a video testing
it out if you guys want to check that
out you can or we'll leave a link to
this down in the description below it is
really cool especially you can just
power it from your iPhone and now it's
time to compare the cameras the pixel
got a major upgrade this year all of the
sensors on the back are close to 50
megapixels compared to only the main
camera on the iPhone now for the selfie
camera we have 10 1/2 megapixels
compared to 12 let's take a closer look
at how this Compares but first I want to
let you guys know that we are going to
do another blind camera comparison I'm
going to bring some people in just like
last time and it was so fun to see their
professional opinion so make sure you
guys are subscribed for that but zooming
into this selfie both of them look
really good I mean the colors are
definitely different as far as detail I
don't really know we have more contrast
on this one you guys let me know which
one looks better to you now Google has
made some software changes as well but
as you can see in portrait mode you
still cannot take a wide portrait like
you can on the iPhone now looking at
this 2x comparison to make it fair here
I would say that I like the pixel shot
better even though some of the details
are crushed it looks more natural with a
little bit more detail which is nice now
even though both of these have 5x
telephoto lenses you cannot take a 5x
portrait with the pixel whereas in the
iPhone we have that nice compression
less stuff in the background and then if
you want to take a closeup portrait like
this you see a lot of warping on the
pixel because it's that main lens
compared to the 5x on the iPhone which I
say looks way better you let me know
your thoughts now getting into some
regular photos both of these are a
standard shot and you see we have a
difference in white balance the pixel is
a lot more dramatic and then if I go
ahead and zoom in well I can zoom in way
more on the iPhone than the pixel and
looking at it the quality is a lot
better because it's a 24 megapixel image
not a 12 now thankfully with the pixel 8
Google finally allows you to take a 50
megapixel image instead of being stuck
to 12 so that's what this is the HDR
does look better on the iPhone but let's
go ahead and take a look at fine detail
now that we can actually take 50
megapixel images and here I would say
the pixel looks better I mean we have
some compression artifacts around but
the iPhone has artifacting on the actual
sign itself now another thing I noticed
when you're taking these highr images on
the pixel it does something kind of like
night mode where asks you to hold it
still which helps it to stack more
images and that is really cool and now
for both 5x lenses here's the shot you
guys could see the pixel is more zoomed
in it's a 30X compared to a maximum of
25 on the iPhone and looking at them
with a similar size I would say the
pixels looks better once again that
stacking and it is is a 48 megapixel 5x
compared to a 12 megapixel and in this
super distant shot the results are
interesting because the pixel has more
detail in this actual house less
artifacting but then if you look at the
rest of the image like the cliff and the
trees well the iPhone looks like it has
a little bit more detail let me know
what you think and lastly we have this
Ultra wide the iPhone once again is only
a 12 megapixel compared to 48
on the pixel right here and looking at
this image it is clear that the pixel
has more detail at least in the high
reses mode the trees look so much more
detailed and it's interesting because
this iPhone just came out it was
impressive but the pixel seems to be
doing a better job and now let's answer
the original question can the pixel 8
Pro stack up to the 15 Pro Max well as
you saw in most categories it it cannot
the iPhone is the flagship but in
certain cases like the cameras it
definitely does a great job so if you
really care about photos and you just
want a great Android experience with
seven years of support now from Google
which is great the pixel is a nice phone
but if you're looking for a more
well-rounded device that is great in all
areas I would say the iPhone is better
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below click that Circle
above to subscribe and check out one of
those great videos right over there this
has been Max and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
one